all right welcome everyone to my first
recap from the Buell chess Festival I
finished about an hour ago and before I
get into the game I want to give a huge
thank you to Alex who came all the way
from Geneva and gave me this amazing
Swiss chocolates he said he lives next
to a chocolate factory and these look
delicious so big thanks to Alex
um coming into this game I had almost no
time to prepare because pairings went up
about 15 minutes before the round but I
think this played into my favor and
we'll see why so I was playing against
uh Steve Papu from Switzerland I was
told after the game that he's one of the
um a young and up and coming players uh
from this country so perhaps a little
bit underrated
and the little preparation that I did
before the game I saw that he plays the
Catalan as white so I was just reviewing
some more General lines and uh we did go
in to the cabinet after uh what starts
as a Queen's Gambit three Knight F6 and
G3 and I decided to play one of my main
weapons that I've used over the years
against the Catalan and it starts with
DC4 Bishop G2 and Bishop to B4 check
this is still pretty well known Theory
and after Bishop to D2 I play a lesser
common line which is Pawn to C5
and this line uh maybe doesn't have an
official name uh but when I play it on
stream I like to call it the Ray Robson
variation a good friend of mine Grand
Master Ray Robson uh played this years
ago before it was even like at all well
known and he won a lot of like really
nice games in the Slime and I like this
line because it's a very confrontational
approach to the Catalan and it's very
offbeat a lot of players are not
prepared for it and I was happy to see
that my opponent uh just started
thinking in this position took a few
minutes before making his next move
and there's a lot to consider here for
whites uh just because there's pressure
between the Bishops and the pawns and
there's a lot of different moves like in
play between taking on B4 taking on C5
castling and leaving the tension A3 is a
move so my opponent uh ultimately
decided to take on B4 and after C takes
B4 he played Queen A4 check and this is
one of the more natural approaches for
White Queen A4 is very common to win
back the pawn and the other idea is
after I play Knight C6 defending the
pawn he has a move Knight E5
and at first this looks very scary for
black given that my knight is pinned and
attacked three times by the Knight
bishop and queen only defended once by
my Pawn but this was actually still
opening preparation on my parts and this
is actually one of the lines that
inspired me to play this opening because
there's a really cool trap that white
can easily fall into especially if uh if
White's not careful so I pretty quickly
played the move Bishop to D7
uh essentially breaking the pin trying
to defend the knights and after my
opponent takes on C6 I take he takes I
take
and from this position it looks like
white is gonna win a pawn because we see
Queen takes c6's check and then uh C4
will hang and my opponent pretty quickly
took on C6 but I'm pretty sure that he
didn't see one of the main points for
black is after I play Knight D7 the C4
Pawn is poisonous and he took some time
here realizing that the pawn is not
capturable and I've had this position
many many times in online Blitz and
bullets maybe I can just check my uh my
reachest stats real quick
let's see as black I've had this five
times on Lee chess probably a few times
on chess.com as well and every time I've
reached this position online my
opponents have taken the poison Pawn
and the reason why this is a blunder for
whites hopefully most of you watching
will see the move for black if you don't
see it feel free to pause the video
Black to move and uh and punish whites
the move is Rook to C8 essentially
skewering the queen and the C1 Square
and there's no way for white to move the
queen and cover C1 and here black is
winning
um a decisive amount of material
so I was not expecting my opponent to
actually allow Rook C8 and uh he made
the right decision to Castle instead and
hold off on taking the pawn
and now we have a kind of interesting
situation where my pawns are a little
bit overextended but they do control
space and that white is threatening to
take on C4 so I play the move Rook C8
hitting the queen and defending the pawn
he plays Queen to A4 hitting B4 and A7
so I played one of the only moves to
defend both pawns which is A5
and then he plays A3
and at this point this is basically out
of my opening preparation from whatever
I looked at like years ago just because
uh not too many players will enter this
line uh without falling for the Trap but
I knew black should at least be close to
equal I was trying to figure out a way
to avoid too much liquidation and a way
to just keep things on the board and try
and play for a win but it wasn't super
simple here because white is ready to
just take on B4
and I ended up playing Queen to B6
reinforcing the b-pawn but then after it
takes takes uh my opponent played a I
think what is a nice move Knight D2 and
it's not so easy to actually keep
everything reinforced and also to Castle
my king because my king is tied down to
defending the Knight which is pinned by
the queen on A4
so by the time we reach this position
I realized it's really not so simple for
black and it's probably white who has
um just a preferable position given that
there's a lot of pressure and these
pawns are more of more of a liability
than a strength for black
so I took a lot of time here we can see
by the timestamps I I was already a
little bit behind on time and I figured
how long I took to make my next move
uh almost half hour to play Queen digs
D4 and the reason why it took so long
was there there's a few options for
white in this position now my opponent
played Queen takes B4 which is probably
the safest approach but there's another
interesting option to play Rook to D1
and the idea with this move is white is
exerting a lot of pressure along the D
file
and my plan here was actually to
sacrifice my Knights I was in a castle
allow a move like Knight F3 and then
take on B2 I thought this would be a
really cool position after Rook takes D7
I am down at night I have two very
dangerous connected past pawns and
um yeah they're either bc3 or B3 or even
Queen takes E2 to start with and I
thought there'd be good chances for back
to uh to play for a win from here
but we didn't go into that because he
played the move Queen jigs before and
this leads to a bit of simplification I
play Rook B8 he plays Queen C3
and we trade and then we get to this end
game which I thought was gonna be kind
of boring and uh very dry but it turned
out to be like really complicated and
intense and uh my opponent actually
found some really strong moves
um after I played King E7 well I was
basically expecting was Knight takes C4
I play Rook C8 I've eventually win back
the C pong like if Knight moves I take
the C pawn and we would get some kind of
draws position which
I wasn't thrilled with but
um I think it's it's really the best way
for black to play she'll also mention
here for K4 my plan was to play Rook C7
and
um eventually I'll form the battery and
win the pawn on C3
but instead of taking on C4 immediately
my opponent played a kind of nice subtle
proprietory move Rook D1 and this move
came as a small surprise because it
looks a bit innocuous at first but the
idea is white is delaying taking on C4
because there's also ideas of Rook A7
and just pressuring my knight and my
king on the seventh rank
and it's a little bit awkward to figure
out what to do here because if I defend
the pawn Rook A7 comes and I'm not sure
if there's like a great move for black
like if I unpin then white gets all this
initiative White's probably already
winning here because Knight's hit and
Knight D6 is coming
so
uh I had to be very careful and I
decided to play Knight B6 defending the
pawn but still allowing Rook A7 which my
opponent played I play King F6 and then
white gets some uh annoying initiative
he plays Knight to E4 my king is almost
uh almost in some sort of mating net but
I do find safety on G6 holding together
uh the king side pawns but it does look
a bit awkward and my opponent keeps
applying pressure with the next move
Pawn to H4
and at this point I realized that I'm
probably in a bit of trouble just
because white has so much better pieces
than than myself and my pieces are not
that well coordinated my king is uh way
more of a Target than any sort of useful
piece even though it's end game and
usually you want to prioritize King
activity uh the king's very awkward on
G6 and White's already threatening to
play H5 to Chase my king away from
defending F7 and I did not want the F
Pawn to fall so I took some time here
trying to figure out what to do I have a
lot of candidate moves considering H5
which I rejected because of Knight G5 I
was also looking at Rook f8 but that
felt a little bit too passive
so I eventually decided to play the move
F6
which looks a bit weakening at first but
the point is after H5 I can safely play
King H6 and keep the G7 Pawn defended
and I'm not losing the pawn on F7
because it's on F6 I thought at least
black is holding on here
and I was expecting to go into this line
where maybe okay white can still apply
pressure and try and set up some forking
ideas but to my surprise my opponent
made a very bad blunder in this position
which I was very much aware of when I
played F6 it looks quite attractive for
white to play the move Rook D6 and just
apply pressure on the six rank given
that E6 is no longer defended so my
point played this move
having spent what seven minutes
and this move is a blunder because it
allows a pretty simple tactic
but the tactic is a very commonly
overlooked type of move
so if you don't see the move for black
feel free to pause the video but it's
back to move and win material
and the move is Knight to C8
and sometimes these backward Night Moves
In this case a backward night Fork can
be a very easy thing to miss
and when I played this move I thought
I'm gonna be easily winning because okay
I'm winning the exchange we're in the
end game we're gonna simplify a little
bit but it wasn't so simple
um because after I play Knight C8 he
played H5
hitting my king and now the idea is if I
take on H5 he can get out of the fork
with Rook A5 check and then save this
rook and um yeah this this position
would not be uh so simple for me so I
played King H6 keeping the king safe
keeping G7 defended and now white has to
lose one of the Rooks he played Rook to
C7 which I think is the best Fighting
Chance pressuring the C pawn and after I
take he takes with the knights and yeah
white has some annoying compensation
here because my C Pawn is undefendable
and there's also ideas of Knight F7
exploiting my king very awkwardly placed
on H6 and my undeveloped Rook from h8
and when I played my next move
I actually instantly regretted it uh the
move I played was Rook f8 which had the
idea of just not getting a fort and now
if Knight F7 I can safely take
um well I should have probably done was
play Rook G8 and we'll see the the
subtle difference between these moves
but after I played Rook f8 my opponent
played a very strong move Pawn to G4
um not only does this defend H5 but it's
setting up the very nasty Knight F7
which is almost Checkmate like if I move
my Rook away it's checkmates now the
reason why I would have really liked my
Rook on g8s in this position with black
to move just for example if I play Rook
G8 and he still plays G4 uh the move I
can play here is King G5
and this move is playable because G7 is
defended
and I'm not getting made at like Knight
F7 I start just scooping a pawns with my
king but when I played Rook f8 then he
plays G4 now if I play King G5 he can
just take on G7 with check
and I did not like the looks of this
even though I was tempted to go into
this line it just looked a little bit
too risky like King H4 and of course I'm
dreaming of King H3 and Rook B1
checkmates but after something like F3
lights pawns are defended and if I play
King G3 I'm not quite forcing mate
because he has 94 and maybe it's my king
who's about to get mated somehow like E3
Rook D7 F4 baby in some lines can create
some mating nuts so going back
once he played G4 I realized it's not so
simple and I was trying to figure out
the best way to still try and create
winning chances and I took a long time
here before playing the move Rook B2
took about 10 minutes on this move and I
played this move completely overlooking
my opponent's response and I think Rook
B2 is a very bad blunder with that said
I'm not sure what I should have played
like maybe
maybe F5 my opponent told me after the
game that F5 is a better chance for
black to play for win
although I wasn't sure about the line
Knight F7 takes takes
takes and then Rook F4 I think white is
very close to drawing this like even
though black is up a pawn in this ending
it's four on three with my double G
pawns I think it's it's hard to actually
convert this
so one of the reasons why I played Rook
B2 was I thought it gave me better
winning chances compared to that line
but my opponent now has a really nice
tactical idea
and it's a bit ironic because a few
moves ago my opponent overlooked this
move Knight C8 which Forks the Rooks in
this position I'm overlooking the same
square
but this time there's Rook C8
and for some reason this move didn't
cross my mind because in most lines I
assumed it's just bad for white to trade
off The Rook
but to my horror if I take the Rook
white doesn't take back white just
delivers mate and uh my stomach just
sank when I saw this move on the board
and for a moment I thought
I might just be losing given that my
Rook is tied down
so this mating idea I really should have
seen this this concept because I was
aware of of Checkmate and other lines it
was just not a move that uh across my
mind so thankfully black is not
completely losing here because I have a
way to
um to try and do some damage control now
I do lose back a bit of material uh
after the move Rook to D2 it was very
sad to have won the exchange a few moves
ago after takes takes I had to give it
right back and not only that but after
Rook C8 this played on the game I'm
losing my C Pawn there's no way to
actually defend and if I try and get
counter play with Rook D1 or Rook D2
it's not enough to win back upon Rook D1
there's this and if this like takes and
defends
so at this point I realize it's gonna be
a bit of torture for me to try and hold
on a rook ending which I'm about to be
down upon so I try to get as much
activity as possible starting with Pawn
to F5 attempting to undermine this mini
Pawn chain my opponent plays F3 winning
Connect Four and after takes takes I was
happy to find a nice Square for the King
which now constantly pressures the
g-pawn now he is able to take and defend
C4 and cover C3 but the good thing for
me is I have a good amount of activity
and White's a bit stuck now with the
Rook because it is tied down to
defending the g-pawn
so I decide to make a small improvement
with E5 he plays King G2 I play Rook D1
I figured the first rank is one of the
most active places for the rook and now
if the king ever moves up there'd be
ideas of Rook 2 G1 to try and pressure
the g-pawn
my opponent plays Rook T4 here and then
I play Rook to C1 so just
counter-attacking the C pawn and yeah
I'm trying to draw at this point so I
would not have minded the trade if takes
I would take and even if Rook C5 it does
keep both pawns defended but I think
this is very very close to a draw
so instead my opponent played the move
Pawn C4 which again keeps the pawns
defended but the drawback of this move
is The Rook ends up getting stuck on the
E4 Square
and after I play the move Rook C3
it's actually very difficult for white
to make any progress so again if takes
I'm happy to liquidate a bit
so my opponent played King F2 and now I
defend the pawn with King F6
and he plays King E1 trying to transfer
the king to attack The Rook I play King
E6 he plays King D2
and then I play Rook to G3 and I offer
to draw here because there's really no
clear way for white to make progress
um the king is cut off on the third rank
if he ever plays C5 that will allow King
D5 and I'll eventually win the C Pawn
and if he plays the move E3 to
potentially allow the king to come in
then The Rook is completely trapped like
there's no more rookie three ideas and I
think I'd be happy here just to play
Rook G2 King C3 and King D6 and White's
just not making any progress like King
b4i check and we can repeat
um so basically what happens is after I
played Rook G3 I offered a draw my
opponent thought for a few minutes and
accepted the draw and
um I'm still trying to process what
happened in the scheme like I think I
had winning chances after getting the
fork earlier but then I was very close
to losing like especially I think
especially in around this position at
least quite as much for Choice and then
even the end game too I thought
um like maybe has some winning chances
with extra Pawn but um yeah overall I'm
not too disappointed and I haven't had a
chance yet to analyze with the engine so
I'm very curious what the engine will
say
but um for those that want to analyze
further I will leave a link to the game
in the video description I will also
leave a link to the full
um full standings and pairings and
tournament websites feel free to explore
the video description and also shout out
to Jonathan schrantz who did take over
my twitch channel for the um for the
first round he did some commentary I
haven't had a chance to watch it but uh
I hope those that did I hope you guys
enjoyed it
and um yeah I don't think there's much
more to say I think it's time to find
some food the next round will be
tomorrow
at 2PM deal time that's 7 A.M U.S
Central time I'm usually in St Louis so
um I'm actually still overcoming some
jet lag but uh be sure to tune in for
the next round and I'll see you guys
soon